right
[Music]
this week Downtown Summerlin will be
filled with haunted Delights with the
debut of Vegas haunt and Vegas
Halloweentown it all kicks off tomorrow
and here tell us more is Birds this is
bird sailor what do you have back behind
you what is this over here hi guys well
this is our beautiful Dasha she is one
of our beautiful North American
performers
so this is a blast we have something for
kids something for is there a zombie
behind me as well this all kicks off
tomorrow let's start with the haunts
because there's a there's a maze down
there a themed maze that people can go
through yeah so pretty much it's gonna
be a vendor it's kind of a vamped up
adult pumpkin patch
cocktails draft beers Pub crawls VIP
lounge at night after the hours get some
of this book here for the adults it
turns a little bit adult theme now we do
have this amazing Halloween Town just
well not just for kids
hi
how are you nice to see you don't bite
so the Halloween Town
well a Halloween Town is a section of it
that is for the children you buy tickets
you get to interact with these awesome
creatures we're gonna have superheroes
there we're gonna have beautiful
princesses now the dinosaur here
the dinosaur kids can get their picture
taken with a dinosaur yes you get to
interact with any of our fun fantastic
creatures you get a ticket you get to
interact with and you get to take
pictures with them maybe if you want to
walk a dinosaur around oh yeah
opportunity to walk a dinosaur I just
need a lock of real life dinosaur yes
where where in downtown Summerlin
Summerlin it's gonna be at the summer on
the launch that's where dinosaurs need
to be dinosaurs and zombies need to be
on the on the lawn and how much is it
how much is it so so for the tickets the
interaction of the children you buy
tickets to any of the attractions we
have face painting we have pumpkin
painting we have churros funnel cakes
you got everything but but wait there's
a special surprise we do have our
beautiful arrow is coming in to have a
free little show for our children and
they're you'll be on a giant 21 foot
upright and you're going to see these
beautiful girls
it's something for everyone thank you
dinosaur thank you zombie and thank you
bird I appreciate it a weekend full of
haunted Delights starts tomorrow runs
through Halloween in downtown Summerlin
we'll be right